during a Taipei game show live stream
armored Core 6 producer yasutako ogura
spoke about what fans can expect from
the upcoming game as well as hitetaka
miyazaki's role in development before we
get into the details let me know in the
comments on a scale of 1 to 10 how big
of an armored Core fan you are according
to ogura continuing the armored Core
franchise was never in question as a
number of Staff members had interest in
making a new title the team wanted there
to be a shorter Gap in between 2013's
armored Core verdict Day and the new
game but with so many other games in the
works over the years the team felt it
had limited resources to work with some
of those other titles include Dark Souls
2 and 3 bloodborne sekiro Shadows die
twice and of course Elden ring the
developers took each lesson learned from
their time on those games and used those
experiences to craft a new type of
action for the armored Core Series
however this doesn't mean the game will
be completely different for returning
fans ogura said armored Core fires
Khan's gameplay is meant to give players
freedom and aims to keep the free
assembly and customization that fans
love that customization will be key to
overcoming the game's difficulty which
is said to be slightly different from
the difficulty of other from software
games due to the trial and error of
trying different Park combinations the
mech assembly is also said to be more
intuitive this time around as to be more
friendly to newcomers of the series the
story is also newcomer friendly and does
not tie to any of the previous games as
for miyazaki's involvement he acted as
fire of rubicon's initial game director
Miyazaki along with co-director and
producer Kenneth Chen worked with others
to create the game's map design actions
and many other core elements of the
game's Foundation armored Core 6 doesn't
have a solid release date yet but The
Last of Us Part One on PC just got a new
one Naughty Dog announced today February
3rd that The Last of Us Part 1 will be
releasing on March 28th and almost 4
week Delay from its original March 3rd
release date but similar to what I said
earlier this week a delay is much better
than a cancellation or a shutdown
knockout city is shutting down Forever
on June 6. the PVP dodgeball game will
no longer be playable with the exception
of a PC only private server version
which will allow the game to live on
forever in a lengthy explanation as to
why the decision was made the team added
that its final season season 9 will
still unfold as normal beginning on
February 28th the 12-week season will
feature six back-to-back events each
going on for two weeks on that same day
February 28th all real money
transactions will be removed from the
game the final season's economy will be
drastically altered as a parting gift to
players including a final premium brawl
pass that will cost just 50 cents as
opposed to the 10 versions of previous
Seasons the final two-week farewell
event called thanks for the Kos will
begin on May 23rd and Usher in the
game's final days I am totally guilty of
falling off of knockout City but man I I
love that game
um so it kind of sucks to see that it's
going away
um but at least I have a decent amount
of time to jump back in enjoy it some
more before it uh it no longer exists in
the same way let me know some of your
favorite knockout City memories drop
them in the comments below and we will
see you again next week foreign